meagan Markel makes her first appearance  since attending Pippa Middleton's  wedding  [Music]  the 35 year old actress attended the 80  X Television Festival in Austin Texas on  Sunday where she sat down with some of  her cast mates for a live table reading  of the original suits pilot in honor of  the show's upcoming 100th episode okay  good good you've hit on me we can get  out of the way that I'm not interested  know what no I'm sorry the rare public  appearance comes just weeks after Megan  attended Pippa Middleton's wedding with  boyfriend Prince Harry et spoke with  Megan's co-star Patrick Jay Adams on  Saturday where he gushed over his  on-screen loves real-life royal  relationship you know Megan and I have  been such good friends and for years now  and to see her so happy it's great she's  super excited so yeah it's very very  very happy for  you